في هذه الاثناء نفى المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني تلقي
عناصر المقاومه في المنطقه اوامره من
طهران واضف كنعاني تعليقا على الهجوم
الاخير على القوات الامريكيه ان الاتهامات
الموجهه لطهران بهذا الشان لا اساس لها
حسب
تعبيره المقاومه في المنطقه لا تتلقى
الاوامر من طهران ولا نرغب في توسيع دائره
الصراع ولا نتدخل في قراراتها للدفاع عن
شعوبها او دعم الشعب الفلسطيني الاتهامات
الباطله التي توجه لايران هي مؤامره يقوم
بها من يرى ان من مصلحته جر الولايات
المتحده الى معركه جديده في المنطقه
وتشجيعها على تصعيد الازمه بهدف التستر
على مشاكله نتابع بحذر التطورات في
المنطقه وعلى الجهات التي توجه الاتهامات
لنا ان تتحمل مسؤوليه اي تداعيات لهذه
الاتهامات
الباطله pouche